this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist coming to you from my
office at the Hayden Planetarium right
here at the American Museum of Natural
History in New York City today is a
cosmic queries edition Startalk and we
will focus on economics not just any
kind of economics we have a special
guest Stephen Stephen welcome and let me
first introduce my co-host first time
Carlos first time James Altucher
so James you are a host of a podcast yes
and when you've been on what what when I
asked you the name of the podcast I
learned it's the James Altucher podcast
yes I'm very I need my name everywhere
everywhere I forget it I think I'm
getting older now and I start to forget
things everyone is getting older at all
times so so Steven tell you so freaking
op you have a podcast yourself
you called Freakonomics radio yeah for
economics radio and so the book just
took over your life huh it did yeah I
liked writing books a great deal but I
you know interviewing people which is I
mean I'm a writer I've been interviewing
gay people forever I always felt bad
about wasting the 95 percent of the
conversation you know when you interview
someone for a magazine article or for a
book you'd use the choicest bits so I
really want to have an interview show so
freakanomics radios chose to put in all
the stuff that is not choice yeah
exactly that's what he just said exactly
right well here's the thing here's the
thing let me ask you this when you get
written but you know remember you're not
the interviewer here then go on I let
this one slide this one this is a tick
I like to ask the question but when you
get written about let's say the New York
Times writes an article about you were
Vanity Fair or something and you read
the things that you say does that feel
like a good representation of you that's
my question of course not right it's I
would say two profiles out of a hundred
that I've read accurately captured right
who wouldn't what I am so I would argue
that mathematically there's a very
obvious reason for that Verity which is
that most articles have a little bit of
the talker and a lot of the writer so
there's a bunch of narrative around a
little quote a podcaster radio show or
interviews
whatever style we've done well can flip
that yes and then the listener or the
reader whatever the listener actually
has what I feel is a truer experience of
what the smart person you're
interviewing has to say and I like that
I'm such a smart person but you bring up
an interesting point which is that if
you the subject you know best is
yourself and if most of the articles
written about you you see are 98 percent
wrong that does suggest that every other
article that we assume is correct is
probably 98 percent wrong that's that
famous adage every article is correct
except the one that you know something
about exactly fake news is actually
probably the average news story yeah
yeah yeah
so James we've solicited questions from
our fan base yes and you've got them
I've never seen them you've never seen
and I don't think Stephen has ever seen
them you know okay I know I haven't I'm
not sure you have them and I'm gonna
believe you because I believe everything
else you've told me earlier so as a
question James give it to me so this is
related probably to a tweet you did
recently but Daniel J Saltzman on
Instagram says what is the economics of
meteor / asteroid mining if you're able
to bring back a huge meteor of diamonds
for example wouldn't that immediately
devalue the commodity so so well that's
it particularly interesting so the let
me quantify this so we have there's
there's more gold on an average metallic
asteroid than has ever been mined in the
history of the world there's more water
on a comet on a typical comet than all
humans who have ever been born have ever
drank so the resources of the universe
of our own backyard our solar system are
extraordinary given what we're fighting
over here on earth yeah to gain access
to so so it's wrong I presume - so we
know it's wrong to say here's the value
of that resource using today's dollars
on earth because you're right if you
make a significant change in the
quantity of a freely traded resource
that is made available that changes the
economics of it so what would you see as
the future if I bring down scabs of gold
so it's interesting their economic Mango
so you changed it to gold so yeah I
would say well just to take a bench more
no I well gold is a national market for
gold gold is a good example because
there's an actual market for it a market
for it unlike diamonds which well gold
market yeah well not only as I'm is a
controlled market but diamonds are not
particularly rare mm-hmm and they're not
I mean there are those who argue that
they are more beautiful that their that
their value is somehow intrinsic but
most people would say that that's not
the case that it was a market that was
created by a kind of very very well done
monopolistic endeavor so really I would
love to see the asteroid full of
diamonds brought down just to break up
the diamond cartel which is convinced
every why you so mean like why do you
here's my cartel I tell you I don't like
don't like cartels diamonds have a
cartel so that they don't represent a a
free market by the way we there are
places in the universe that also have
scans of diamonds but not large pre-cut
yeah very tiny or some of them are
almost microscopic they serve the
industrial marketplace for diamonds man
could tell me about gold I bring I bring
Barnes worth of gold to earth what
happens yeah it change it changes a lot
in ways that I can't even begin to
imagine anyone that's even kind of
pretending to work off a gold reserve
idea which we don't work off an actual
gold reserve we used to I guess I used
to but now we weren't kind of off the
idea of it no it's a precious metal that
would change I so i depressions because
it's where rare precious it's useful
it's a very good question gold
historically yeah it's pretty useful
it's soft it's really you cetera does
much the same uses no no well the gold
is softer than silver silver is also is
silver not antimicrobial two or can it
be it is that's why it's yeah I mean
it's well I think but I would be more
interested in water personally because
gold you know gold has functions and
uses if it's beautiful and functional
um diamonds you know mostly a decorative
thing but water supply so that's awesome
so I would be so if we're starting to
talk about asteroid mining or resource
mining then yes I am
it would you go for the water I would go
for any resource that is
necessarily consumed by everybody on
earth way ahead of gold and diamonds so
for instance I've learned recently you
probably know about this I don't know
anything about other than that
satellite imagery now allows us to map
out global water supply in aquifers that
we never used to be able to do so that's
really useful because it's multispectral
imagery you get different that's what I
was going to say multispectral so the
the notion of asteroid miner resource
mining I think is revolutionary
generally fantastic and most so because
it would help put resources in the power
of the global citizenry as opposed to
the cartels or whatever that have done a
pretty good job of monopolizing
resources pretty socialistic thing
yeah that's not no I it's not quite so
obvious because first off there would be
an enormous amount of resources required
to get sure yeah and bring it back the
atmosphere right second gold primary use
was because it was rare it became a
currency because it was hard to mine but
so it will in the long run you know
affect the price downwards supply and
demand but I think the resources would
be so difficult to get it so this is why
what all the space resource people are
talking about if you're gonna get it in
space it's to deliver to some other
location in space right where there's a
colony or there is a station getting
built because if you're building
something in space and you don't have to
launch it from Earth then just build
factories in space and take all of your
royal of raw materials and and you can
give them bottles of water this would be
like Trump Hotel on Mars if it's like he
finds gold and then they make like a
whole you can move that goal to his
hotel and gild everything in his hotel
right like gram Mars would be from Mars
gilded toilet seats yes what kind of
resources are most easily moved from out
there to here any no it doesn't matter
all the matters is weight to accelerate
it to slow it down
to move it from one point in space to
another so it could be a pound of gold
or a pound of water
it'll cost you the same to move the
thing around the solar system
and depending on where it is in the
asteroid the mining effort would be the
same right if it's you know a few feet
down or half a mile down and the
asteroid that that's effort so liquid
solid gas none of that matters just wait
it's not gonna be liquid out there but
it'll just be the way yeah the the state
of the matter doesn't yeah you'd be
bring down ice but you can't have a
liquid gold like in the center of an
asteroid no you've wanted you need high
pressure temperature and you're not
getting that in a center of an asteroid
so here's the thing so gold here's a
problem yeah Gold is very heavy it's one
of the densest known things when we
think of when we joke about dense things
we talk about lead right well you got a
lead foot you're driving fast on the on
the highway lead is nothing compared
with the platinum group elements osmium
platinum gold right these so so osmium
is the densest of all metals and so one
cubic foot of that weighs last I checked
I calculated this in in middle school I
remember 1800 pounds gold just slightly
less than that might come in maybe 1650
1700 pounds so let me add something that
I think you left out here that just
because there's a lot of it doesn't mean
it would become as devalued as you think
because there are uses that previously
are on or not economically tenable right
that then become economically tenable
and the demand for that use goes up fair
enough
let's say you said I use a gold is one
of the highest conducting metals in the
electricity like better than copper okay
so in terms of electrical conductivity
and another use is it can it's highly
malleable so that's why you have gilt
gold gilded statues and and so there
might be some need to hammer gold thin
and layer it onto something out there
that could benefit from that fact gold
hardly ever corrodes if you need highly
non corrosive material the famous
Voyager record that was sent into space
that contained messages and sounds from
earth that was a gold record it would
last a billion years so what do you have
so someone could invent a new Renu
reason to use gold right and that
would completely transform the
marketplace so what about here's a
lottery story here energy storage here's
one so aluminum is a modern element who
was not known to the ancients as common
as it is today you think they've always
not know it was locked up in bauxite the
the ore that who knew that aluminum was
a thing to take out of it when aluminum
was extracted you know the first person
said after that that's the end of the
silver market hmm because you can make
silver out of it Wow for for less and
there's more of it right although the
the the the cost economic as well as
environmental cost of extracting it is
high but not anymore but anyhow we've
gotten better at it my point is once
aluminum rose up it was like oh it's
light and it's strong we can make
airplanes out of it all of a sudden you
can do things that you never thought you
could do before do you remember uh do
you remember Howard Hughes's famous
airplane it was on display unless you
know what's called Spruce Goose made of
wood it's made of wood just what is
light right okay before a lot of
aluminum was available and I always
wonder if we never discovered aluminum
what would we be making planes up would
be making them out of wood we made so
many planes
yeah we'd all be flying a lot less
probably is my guess yeah so the
existence of a single element and its
properties unique on the periodic table
burst entire economic industries that
then created a demand far above what you
had ever declared to be its value as a
cherished object to put on your shelves
it makes me want to ask you if you know
anything about I know nothing about this
so there's silicon chips right so we've
been doing doing well with it but what
about organic semiconductors you know
anything about that and the stuff that's
used in those and whether is that a
difficult problem to solve you know if
it's organic it's made of the most
common ingredients in the universe right
but I'm not worried about rarity there
right but apparently there in parenting
pliable enough that conduct well enough
right so then that either we will and
then that'll transform the industry or
we won't and it's just a failed but we
don't need any a software that oh no no
no no all the elements
story there on earth there's just in
greater abundance so rare stuff what
should we be like all the rare earth
elements there on asteroids you know
potato burger here except in China
except in China common in China China
has most of the rare earth elements
within their borders which by the way is
used heavily by the semiconductor
industry yes indeed all right another
question another question give it to me
it's from our weak subramanyam and
Instagram are there ways to notice the
onset of another recession is recession
an inevitable event happening in cycles
oh you're not gonna get the answer to
that until we return on Startalk
we're back on Startalk cosmic queries
economics not just any kind of economics
this Freakonomics and I got James out
sure out shirt
I didn't say James first-timer yes yeah
yeah yeah when he speaks you're just
listening he's supposed to interrupt him
and tell him why he's very hard and I
feel he's been interrupted for 20 years
so we entered the commercial break with
a question about a read the question
again so we can have it are there ways
to notice the onset of another recession
is recession inevitable event happening
in cycles so let me brought who I asked
that question I reek saranya from
Instagram I chilled by the way I get my
kata your cadence also when I'm talking
like you know are there ways to notice
me I don't even I don't speak like that
in that way alright so let me broaden
that by saying why should economics have
cycles at all hmm why isn't it just a
straight line why there's boom and bust
why why well well well by the way does
is there such a thing as cycles I don't
necessarily believe cycles is a thing
let me not even use that word why do
things go up and down why I mean the the
shortest answer I could give is because
give me a freakanomics answer because
the world is stochastic
it just is right
and then if you look at the economy so
they answer the question isn't the point
of the Federal Reserve to modulate yeah
the stochastic well imagine imagine how
less modulated it would be if I was
passing to define for those who not
everyone knows the definition of that
word random ish I would say yeah
sarcastic it's it can be sort of
predictably random and analytically
random yeah so completely it's not the
reason economics is a sign it's not
completely random there's some things
you can predict and it's nice of you to
say that economics is a science because
there are those who would argue that
it's not it's a social science
technically but an answer that so the
people there the question specifically
about Ken a recession be predicted so
like you know there's a there's one
saying that economists have predicted
like 18 of the last three recessions so
there is such a thing there's a
technical definition of a recession
which has to do with you know a decrease
in is it employment is it you would know
that too but the National Bureau of
Economic Research declares a recession
decline in change we know that because
he has prior history he does in his name
you're kind of so before you became a
comedian I was a hedge fund manager
hedge fund manager and I was as what
manager through two recessions and you
weren't making enough money she said I'm
going oh no I'm a comedian I I was gonna
make a joke about that you totally
messed up my joke again and I just see
the joke coming I I didn't you didn't
make enough money as a hedge fund
manager so you try to take up comedy
right because it was performing in front
of 12 people on a Monday so isn't it
true that if everyone is right about
what will happen they will bet in such a
way that prevents it from happening but
their behavior will be such that it
won't happen but that's the problem is
that they're very bad at predicting yeah
we're bad at predicting world there's
also arbitrage so when there's an
obvious opportunity for some people to
profit from a downturn right that gets
baked in
the and maybe pulled out of the markets
but bottom line we have gotten much
better at we like I have something to do
with it the modern world has gotten
better at modely moderating or
modulating the way the economy works so
what you're left with
in fact right when the Great Recession
happened which is when which was 11
years ago now right it began 1229 was
that sorry the Great Recession sorry all
right sorry and migrates yeah it was a
Great War the Great Recession the Great
Depression generations a great yeah
great big gobs of Great Gatsby yeah dry
me gopher guts but so tell me the the
Great Recession the Great Recession 2008
yes yeah 2007 2008 there were most
economists who watched the macro economy
at the time in the long run they were
talking about the period that we were in
right then 2007-2008 as what they called
the Great Moderation
they were trying to name our era then
the Great Moderation what they meant by
that is there will be no more big
recessions so that's how good macro
economist are at predicting the future
they said the same in nineteen ninety
nine ninety nine for the mm yeah yeah
although that one was in some ways I
don't want to say easier to see but the
proximate cause was staring us in the
face more whereas yeah but if it was
that obvious people would have bet the
other way and it wouldn't well there
were people who bear the other way in
the mark there would have been more
people who would have bet the other way
too yeah boy buoyed that effect but fear
and greed sort of comes to place in
maximum is right before recession starts
so this blinds everyone maximum fear and
greed happens right before a cycle
change so that's what happened in what
good is that for you to say it after the
fact nothing alright so they don't know
when you are maximally blinded by fear
and greed to say it after the fact
doesn't help anyone do anything all
right so let's put skin in the game
right now and say here we are in 2019 on
a scale but say one to ten how
vulnerable do we feel the American
economy is in let's say a five year time
window Oh five years let's say five
years ten being catastrophic and one
being everything kind of
okay so on the scale on account of three
we say our number right one two three
sighs okay okay so what I will say it's
gonna be great for the next two years
right and then it's gonna be potentially
horrible would you bet it would you bet
on that yeah you would yeah okay so get
it short every stock in two years no no
no I was just betting on it nope being
in cash is betting on it because I think
it's gonna be so bad that's not that's
that that's not betting on it I'm at
servitor fact that's not betting on it
it is I think the value of cash will go
up it's fine but if you can if you
really think everything's gonna tank you
will short everything and you'll make
even more money as we all learn in the
big short and so you're not actually
betting on it you're wimping out by
pulling out your cash waiting for things
to happen before you jump back in thanks
for announce to the world I'm an Omega
Steven isn't a Myra correct that he's
not actually I love that you're
encouraging him to engage in the most
reckless broke short who's your
financial the next question what do you
have oh by the way creative investments
in science and technology
yeah our reliable engines of tomorrow's
economic growth so if you want to talk
about boom and bust the busting is
usually gonna happen when you don't have
some meaningful return on your or no
investments at all well this is right
next industries that could actually keep
you buoyant what do you have so this is
from the Musial studio from Instagram
mm-hmm do you feel that investing more
in space-exploration can help boost our
economy ooh God yeah by the way I'm
gonna answer it public versus private
should the government be investing or
should billionaires be investing okay I
wrote an entire book on this called
space chronicles and I write books so
that I never have to talk about that
subject again can you write a book about
politics and please I've never acted so
I have an unorthodox answer to that and
I'd like to get your Steven your
feedback on it
so people think of spin-offs
if you value all the spin-offs direct
spin-offs from NASA relative to what
we're spending on answer they do not pay
for NASA
so the spin-off argument is they let the
spin-off a man sir tang oh yeah do we
sell 18 billion dollars a year in tank
so we're talking about technology
inspired by the work technology
derivative of research done to put
people and maintain their lives in space
okay people and and robots space
endeavors and creative people have to
invent something to solve a problem hey
this works on earth one such example is
tempur-pedic mattresses temper temper
foam that was invented for space travel
through a space exploration yet it's an
entire industry of mattresses now it's
not an eighteen billion dollar a year
industry which is approximately NASA's
budget so that's not the argument but
wait let me just ask you what about
let's say the computing effort that were
put into early space so a lot of people
who say that that computing environment
accelerated the development of computing
generally which led to things like the
development of the energy etcetera it
made it happen faster but it didn't
create computers that wouldn't have been
created already and it's interesting you
make that argument cuz you've made a
sort of opposite argument with like
bringing a bunch of gold that's saying
in other words we find uses for and grow
right our we change our world based on
the resources available I mean how do
you know that the computers that we use
for NASA were not usable in your room
somebody has to step up and say right
let's make this a home computer and the
internet was initially funded by DARPA
project agency which you could argue was
affiliated with the space development
well it was very useful in space and
plus the connecting computers was
invented by physicists at a particle
accelerator in Europe at CERN so so this
is again the engine of tomorrow's
economic growth my point is very
different from all of these if we agree
that innovations in science and
technology are tomorrow's engines of
growth economies I don't think that's a
controversial for the sake of argument
I'll agree with that yeah I don't think
I don't think it's a controversial
statement
then if you have an active space
exploration program which would require
government investment private industry
can't do what I'm about to describe you
want to advance a space frontier and
companies will fail at this because
there's no market place for advancing a
space frontier it's too expensive it's
too dangerous and the return on that
investment
is indeterminate until it becomes
routine except for the last question
where we did feel okay let's get gold
from the asteroids and water from the
asteroids and now all the world but
that's an engineering frontier we've
already been to asteroids
that's not advancing a space frontier
we've already know we've landed on
asteroids so now you just have to land
and dig and bring it back so so the
government landed on an asteroid before
a private enterprise did that's the only
point I'm making here all right private
enterprise is not gonna do anything
first in space because to do something
first in space has no obvious next
return on that investment but a
government can do it because a
government has a much longer time
horizon than you quarterly report or any
annual report required of investors
being a public or private in private and
impressed so point is watch what happens
you eat we go into space in a big way
we're gonna put people on Mars well who
we're gonna go there in 15 years
well who would those astronauts gonna be
well they're in middle school now let's
go find them and have like the mercury
seven but now they're like 14 years old
and they'll be in teen beat they'll be
in all these magazines and we'll all be
watching our they have are they eating
well are they not doing drugs are they
what's their social live through the
teachers like them and we follow them
into adulthood and they are our heroes
that we send and everybody gets jazz
about going into space and to do that
requires advances because with no one's
sent people to Mars before requires
advances in in Electrical Engineering
mechanical engineering in physics
chemistry biology the entire portfolio
of stem field is stoked by an entire
generation of students who have as their
hero people whose journey is enabled by
creativity in those fields that would
transform our economy like no
other force exists you know we're doing
now we got to go to country we need
money to have a program to tell people
that they should study science if you
have kids selected we're gonna be the
first ones going to Mars people will be
jumping over each other to try to learn
science and you'll need a special
program to make it happen so your answer
to that question is yes in the way I
described yes what's the point of
sending people to Mars
there's no point but but um Steven let
me ask you how nimble is the investment
community in seeing opportunity that
could open up new opportunities nimble
is an interesting word they're super
nimble but they're also fairly cowardly
okay that's an that so you have Amazon
trying to put us so Jack be nimble Jack
walk around the table oh here here's an
armed member but he's walking around
this here here's an argument that some
people make and that I find has some
truth in it which is that venture
capital and private equity have built a
great reputation for funding a lot of
innovations of the Silicon Valley sort
of the Silicon Valley store so in space
SpaceX charging lakhs well that's a
large that's a little bit different
because a lot of those are more vanity
projects not all but some are which is a
little bit different and want to make
money yeah yeah but they're just funded
different at this point as you know much
if you want to make a small fortune in
space yes start with the big four yeah
but um the the argument is that the
story that we tell ourselves about
venture capital and private equity is
these are unbelievably brave pioneers
who seek out right that that's the
whereas in fact what they are are smart
motivated people who take pension funds
primarily that have been earned by
California schoolteachers and find a
place to park it in a in something like
an uber or a lyft and that's great and
there are some upside to that but the
there is an argument to be said that
government funding of science basic R&D
bench science over the years and
pharmaceuticals in space and computing
etcetera are wildly wildly wild
underappreciated and undervalued in part
because it's a government's own fault
for not getting a return on those
investments that what was the last time
you took a drug that was made by the
government yesterday every drug sale now
was basically rounded by always the
Institute of the first round there's no
return on the first round you have to
know the thing exists first and that's
what Christ's huge investment and often
it happens in collaborations with
universities this sort of thing so yeah
so great point and here's something we
all use touchscreen monitors
touchscreens
that that was invented on an NSF grant
does there at the Library of Congress
yeah to have people interact with the
screen that didn't have to require a
mouse and so some innovative people
invented the touchscreen so the
government doesn't toot its horn but
what the government does do is release
the the patents so that you make a
boatload of money and then you pay taxes
back to the government which absolutely
yeah
but I'm very intrigued by your proposal
that if you had the Teen Dream Mercury
team Mars team what it would do I think
that's really an interesting scenario to
consider do you they would come back
heroes as people who have been explorers
in the history of civilization have been
well I'm also just interested in what
your snow as ever has ticker tape parade
for a robot right but what their
existence would do to the next
generations of people because you're
right
we tell people learn stem because it's
good for you and it's good for us and we
got and they're looking why don't why
because I there's no there's no
landscape out there for them to to
arrive on after they've actually gone
through that you imagine how annoying
these kids would be though like before
you're 13 we're gonna set up your
Instagram account also boom like you
know it's like quantum mechanics once
you start observing something the
behavior changes now you can start
observing Eric the whole world's will be
observing these the new right stuff
they're gonna be like all Lindsay Lohan
or whatever
I don't want those oh that no we got to
take a break when we come back more
economics specifically Freakonomics on
start on Startalk we're back I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson I've got Stephen Dubner
here I've got James Altucher each of
them has a podcast only one of them
named the podcast after himself
and that would be James wouldn't it I
feel like I have to apologize just call
it like I don't know freaka for economy
word freak is good freak is good so
Stephen W Freakonomics a best-selling
book internationally best-selling book
just congratulations on thanks can I
talk can I tell him one story Stephen
about the book yes please okay so this
is almost 18 years 17 years or whenever
it was the day before the book comes out
Stephen and I are having lunch you were
worried I'm not gonna say what you said
but you were worried you didn't know how
the book would do and you were scared
and I said I was lying I was just being
nice I said don't worry it's gonna be a
big hit cuz I read the galley but I just
was being nice I didn't know and then
you called me a few days led later you
said check out Amazon's rankings and I
figured all it'll be like number a
thousand number 2000 and you're like no
just check out the rankings okay number
one was Harry Potter number two for
economics for the next year and a half
it was number two was Freakonomics I was
really jealous but never wrong I'm wait
wait wait that's a story that's a story
if you really nervous it's really a
story about Harry Potter yeah
unfortunately all right we got more
questions yeah let's do it yeah we only
bid through three questions today let's
see if we can get some more what okay
this is gum launch pad cat on Instagram
what is the most important thing to look
for when determining if studies slash
statistics are trustworthy ooh great
question depends if you're a scientist
or not if you know how to read the
scientific paper
I think there's anything a layperson can
say which is how big is the sample size
what are the confounding factors what
are the alternate explanations and what
is your degree of confidence in your
conclusion those are some basic
questions I would say in physics we have
it easy
and if
comics they have in hard because in
physics if we find a new law of the
universe it will repeat every single
time whereas in economics if you
discover a new pattern and then you
invest knowing that pattern the act of
investing changes what that pattern
becomes right so you become as James
you'd mentioned earlier you become sort
of a quantum participant in the
experiment itself yeah also I feel with
economics the motor effect most ray oh
but most things are like bell curve
statistics but there's also the power
law of earthquakes
it'll involved and you can never predict
that as the problem which is why it's a
social science I would say we can never
predict earthquakes we just don't know
how now we don't know how true but it's
a different kind of statistics as far as
we know and but in physics okay you're
an observational physicist in
theoretical physics I don't know if you
can say that about theoretical physics
papers say what like let's say you have
a frontier most are wrong but once
everything agrees and it matches
observations we have a new understanding
of the universe it's why we have modern
civilization right yeah economics has
about one law that's like a physics law
and it's basically supply and demand and
how price works within that but even
that gets violated sometimes so yeah
it's a very different kind of science
right next question go James you're
picking them I'm gonna pre answer yes
okay private versus public health care
what what's better for the economy and
what's better what's more moral there's
I don't know I don't do morrow
you don't do moral I think it's a
mistake to do morrow as a I think it's
good to do morrow as a first step but
then when you get into analysis and
descriptive policy and so on you got to
turn off put away the moral compass yeah
man this could deeply influence for
example it'd be in my field with regard
to possible future contact with alien
intelligence if an alien shows up on
earth and it's smarter than us and you
kill it is it murder if it's not itself
human right so our laws only talk about
humans but something more intelligent
than you so so so these are things I
think are worse fold
into how you I think about the problem I
think morality is hugely important but
when it comes to doing analytical
rallies really really important but let
me finish is really important and okay
okay if you want to be an and guy
instead of a butt guy be an and guy but
it's incredibly important to put aside
your personal moral compass when you're
trying to analyze like a particularly
social issue because and this is why we
see so much bad policy you see people
making policy decisions based on what
they hope or wish will happen where fear
may happen and we humans are just smart
enough to find confirmatory evidence of
what we believe and ignore evidence that
would negate it and so I just go into
situations trying to think you know what
whatever I feel about this particular
issue
gun control climate change whatever
whatever I feel about it move it to the
side and let's try to look at the data
first so that's what I mean by what the
problem is is never any data like so
like let's say the government says in
1965
oh we're gonna back off student loans
nobody's ever done it in the US so where
there's no data and now tuitions go up
10x faster than inflation
well you but you can't say that cuz I
mean a lot of European governments do
actually Garan I mean they guarantee
universal education through college like
how does universal differently bigger
than earth so for earth miss universe is
like prettiest person on earth not in
the whole universe okay so so earth wise
getting back to the health care question
the question what's better I think the
answer is I'm not gonna say what's
better or worse I think the answer is it
is bizarre that the United States is the
only rich country in the world that a
doesn't have a national health care
system
I say bizarre not terrible bizarre and
it's also bizarre that we traditionally
have had a health care system that's
been tied to employment which is
basically an accident of history going
back to the Second World War
do you think that all knew all of this
they would all think and vote
differently about health care
not really honestly but but here's where
I think the the conversation needs to
happen I think if people want to talk
about socialism being wonderful or
terrible they need to understand what
socialism is and most of the people who
are promoting socialism as wonderful and
terrible for that matter don't know what
socialism is so what they admire our
socialist democracies like Scandinavia
but that doesn't mean that the state
owns the oil companies exactly so um
when we look at like Scandinavia and
other countries that have good
earth-wide it's it's it's worth noting
that that is not a socialist in the way
that it's used as an epithet and so
would it be better for the economy for
there to be some kind of a reform system
where costs could be controlled then the
answer is a gigantic huge yes the
problem is I mean you I'm guessing you
see this in your science a lot more than
we see it in our science when assist
when there's a lot of entropy or inertia
or whatever how do you undo that the
healthcare lobbies are really rich and
really strong and why would they want to
undo it so that's a big that's a big big
big barrier and also look where
government like does the FDA really help
the drug approval process and and this
is even related at a scientific studies
question how many drugs get recalled
even after they've been through all the
studies I mean some would say that the
FDA for thalidomide per se was one of
the best uses of public science in the
history of the world I mean that was
actually that was an after you know um
flow that might was widely used around
in Europe and other places the world the
reason it wasn't here was because of I
think it was a single FDA officer and
she just said I think we haven't seen
enough data to make a call on this so so
but but even that really set the stage
for the next 45 years of maybe some
reluctance sir or whatnot all right
another question another question give
it to me this question is from Arie
moody at patreon how is AI gonna change
statistics and economics oh yeah we're
ji landing right now is AI going to
change statistic I will become the
richest thing
there ever was hmm I just whined thing I
don't know what day I is if it's it's
not animal vegetable or mineral
it's mineral right I guess so so if I
have an AI computer and it's smarter
than I am and it figures out the market
and it becomes a trillionaire overnight
right and we'll just stare at it and
there it is it goes off on its private
jet and wonder and wonder if it's gonna
kill us
eh I though that plays chess that flies
planes but not a single AI can tell me
if an apple tastes good so I can't
really replace humans I would say not
yet not yet it's to come I liked it but
get back to AI in economics yeah isn't
isn't that kind of what these complex
trading programs are doing yeah the
marry using hardcore statistics rather
than AI yeah well they're making
decisions on the fly yeah based on
information it had never seen before
right but was like any crimes right but
primed by what has happened in the past
right that's what any of us do right so
I'm not gonna say that's not AI there's
there's like strong AI weak AI and
general AI okay we can slice and dice
but if you have a computer making buying
and trading decisions based on
information that it is getting on its
own then it has a potential to be the
richest thing in the world um I don't
know if that's true and we really do all
pretty much have that now that sounds
like you know it's not true when you say
you don't know that it is true what's
your skepticism
um the problem is in the markets there's
one of the biggest factors in the
markets is human psychology mm-hmm so AI
I mean we're always gonna be better at
that the machine's not at producing it
not necessarily analyzing it sorry
yeah we won't be better analyzing we'll
always be better at producing it because
we introduced that chaos into the system
but to me the biggest gate I think about
AI the way you were describing let's say
we bring back boatloads boatloads full
of gold
what does AI do for the human experience
we don't know yet will it expand it an
augment it make it awesome I'm sure on
some dimensions will it make it very
constricting I'm sure on other
dimensions that's true I think you
dogs used to be animals of labor they
did a lot of pulling stuff and they did
they did a lot of labor for us and then
we found better things to do that
including machines and then we turned
them into pets so we actually have more
dogs around now than we did when they
were workers so I'd like to think that
we humans we could be lovely pets for
the robot yeah absolutely I think we'd
be you know with a wealthy AI that's
trading here's the bond that happens
here's a problem that happens is that
once you have AI that is making money
everybody else sees it and then they
make AI to model that and so it gets you
mentioned it earlier in another question
it gets arbitrage dawei so advantages
change very quickly and and you always
have to have the next AI very fast to
change to take advantage of that so just
it's it's its second generation AI yeah
that kicks the ass or the first
generation AI and then in the future
there'd be the hundredth generation AI
that then controls the universe let me
get one last question we do it let me
see how if you're good at sound bytes go
okay do you think that the economy would
react better to a moon base or a
long-term mission to Mars moon base or a
long-term mission to Mars how would the
economy react better moon base because
of what you said earlier errors minerals
yeah you want a way station for bringing
back though no I'd say thrown asteroids
no what hardly any no but you wanna you
want a close place to process stuff
don't you don't you want to that has
value but it has less ambition yeah but
it's like an Amazon warehouse in New
Jersey I don't need to come all the way
from Seattle I need my coffee tomorrow
right
the moon is is is three days away yellow
moon prime yesterday delivered on earth
but by space drones right okay well make
a good point and I retract my statement
about Mars being cooler because the moon
will be much more practical we can
disagree that's okay I'm comfortable
with that
what arguments what's what's more
interesting to you somebody landing on a
passing asteroid or someone landing on
Mars Mars will take more more innovation
to pull that off and as a scientist that
likes seeing the moving frontier of
our knowledge at Mars landing but what
if someone's gonna use the asteroid as
their rocket to get to Mars mm-hmm yeah
that's the it's better just use your own
rocket yeah really great for Mars and if
it is you're gonna be dead when it hits
so yeah it's just not a wise thing how
worried are you about an earth ending
asteroid strike generally a life on
Earth ending asteroid earth will be here
long a life on earth ending yes you
should we should all invest some amount
of money and to mitigate that risk so
for all of our guests we give them a
chance to ask me a question if they've
been harboring any sort of unanswered
thoughts about the unit I've been
harboring I do have a question for you I
think this is a really minor thing but
it's something that I wonder about which
is contamination so I know that our if I
smell so I know that at JPL Jet
Propulsion labs in Pasadena California
which is which does a lot of NASA
research - branch of NASA yeah they they
and others are concerned that our
everything that we spend it send us into
space doesn't spread our microbes around
and the things that come back from
wherever don't it is that a major
concern oh yes it's an entire office of
NASA called the office of planetary
protection right and it protects other
planets from our microbes and it
protects our planet from whatever
microbes might come back if we have what
we call a sample return mission or if we
send astronauts and then they might come
back contaminating the original Apollo
11 astronauts were put in a in a what do
you call that containment and whatever a
quarantine yeah we do in quarantine but
I keep saying winnebago but it's with
what's it was not a Winnebago going
dream you know the the metal silver air
sorry in the Airstream thank you that so
the astronauts would put it like an
Airstream and you can only talk to them
through the window and through the
telephone right and that was to make
sure that they didn't bring any bugs
back from the moon we'd learned that
they didn't because life campus as we
know it can't survive on the moon but
but it was still the gesture was an
important fact that look people we don't
want to cross-contaminate
when that has happened in the history of
exploration on earth it is never voted
well for typically the people who got
visited by
it would be so interesting to know
however if there were antibodies or
whatever any kind of microbes it would
be useful in our earth science here
right when that we've certainly never
evolved it in our bodies though well we
don't know that I mean you know a little
bit more about the Big Bang than I do
but isn't there a chance that there's a
piece of that in all of us yes a piece
of what what whatever is in us is out
there yeah rain Adams so theoretically
there may be some underlying principles
of cancer that we haven't yet understood
well because we haven't seen it modeled
in a way that we can what we would do is
yet do a download on the brilliance of
the aliens who have come to visit they
will know more about practically
everything we got to end it there
guys thanks for coming on thanks yeah
well a little economic twist to all of
this because as they say freshly minted
graduates scientist engineer and
economists and they pose a question to
the life they're about to lead the
scientists asks why doesn't the engineer
asks how does
an economist asks and that is the
civilization you've been listening to
possibly even watching Startalk
I want to thank Freakonomics Stephen
Dubner Stephen thank you for my pleasure
I'm James Altucher
recently married congratulation thank
you yeah and thanks for coming on thank
you very much thanks for having all
right I've been Neil deGrasse Tyson and
I still will be even after we finish
this this broadcast and I want to thank
you for listening to possibly even
watching Startalk as always I bid you to
keep looking up
you